massive emergency food distribution is
underway right now over at sam boyd
stadium
the culinary academy of las vegas says
local families are in dire need right
now with the holidays that are here
hector mejia is live for us this
afternoon with the details hey hector
hey there we've seen thousands of cars
lining up all day and just check out how
long the line is the line here wraps
around
all around this parking lot here at
samboyd stadium
and it continues down this side and off
to the left that is where we have about
six lines
drivers waiting in line to pick up a
free basket with groceries
this is scheduled for today and tomorrow
however you'll want to listen to this
reservations were required and they are
full for both days
and that just speaks about the need the
impact has been so widespread in nevada
a lot of us know someone who has been
affected by the layoffs
and the culinary academy of las vegas
tells us that people are feeling an
unprecedented level of food insecurity
many also struggling with rent utilities
other expenses
and to make the holidays a little easier
the nonprofit teamed up with the just
one project
to give away fifteen thousand boxes
today and tomorrow here at sam boyd
stadium
then they'll hand out five thousand more
in rural communities
including laughlin moapa and mesquite
they've been helping families since
march i should tell you when we first
started this
many of the people obviously that were
first displaced were people that work in
the hospitality industry
we would open trunks and people would
leave us
notes of kindness and gratitude people
would leave us
tips or attempt to leave us tips and so
here it is
people that were just laid off would
leave their last three or four or five
dollars now obviously
we wouldn't take it but it just really
speaks to who we are
as a community
so heartwarming to hear and let's talk
about what's in the box
large cuts of roast beef plus rice
pasta and a whole range of vegetables
including zucchini
butternut squash potatoes carrots celery
cabbage everything
and cars as you can see are still
streaming through but again
they're out of reservations reporting
live from saving boyd stadium hector
mejia
will be back right after